[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
80% des personnes souffrant de la fin
dans le monde sont des paysans
en France en 50 ans
on a perdu plus de 4 paysans sur 5 une
véritable casse sociale
le taux de suicide des agriculteurs est
40% supérieur à la moyenne de la
population
en France toujours on perd des terres
agricoles avec l'artificialisation des
sols au rythme de 1 terrain de foot
toutes les 7 minutes
en des chiffres pour vous expliquer la
tragédie du monde agricole je peux vous
en citer plein
mais vous pourrez les découvrir dans des
films des documentaires des conférences
et malgré cette réalité qui s'impose à
nous
moi je voulais vous dire que je suis un
paysan heureux
merci
[Applaudissements]
pourtant
pourtant au départ j'avais pas imaginé
mener cette vie là
mon père éleveur de volaille industriel
répétait sans cesse les garçons ne
faites jamais ce métier on a connu plus
stimulant pour créer une vocation
alors j'ai fait des études d'ingénieurs
en agriculture justement pour comprendre
comprendre comment on produit comprendre
comment faire pour que sur cette planète
tout le monde puisse manger à sa faim
parce que depuis toujours moi j'aime
manger
alors mon parcours en agriculture a été
semé de quelques désillusions
en 2004 d'abord je pars aux États-Unis
dans le Nord Dakota pour un an le
bastion mondial du maïs et du soja
j'y vais pour me faire ma propre opinion
sur les OGM vous savez les organismes
génétiquement modifiés et pour répondre
à la question suivante ces innovations
technologiques et génétiques
sont-elles une solution à la fin dans le
monde
ma réponse est claire c'est non elle
servent essentiellement des intérêts
financiers ma première désillusion
ensuite en 2006 toujours à armée de ma
grande naïveté je pars au Brésil
là pour faire une étude pour les
exportateurs de blé français
au même moment je découvre le mouvement
des paysans sans terre qui explose dans
le pays
je comprends que non seulement
le commerce international ne nourrit pas
le monde mais qu'en plus les paysans
producteurs d'alimentation peine
eux-mêmes à se nourrir faute d'accès aux
fonciers
deuxième désillusion
de 2009 à 2011 ma femme et moi partons à
Madagascar
dans un petit village où tout le monde a
de quoi manger grâce à la production
locale
ailleurs dans le pays la population
meurt de faim
Madagascar un pays autrefois autonome en
riz qui aujourd'hui dépend des
importations comment une situation
pareille est-elle possible
en fait
les terres et l'alimentation sont
considérés comme n'importe quel autre
valeur marchande c'est un non sens pire
ça va à l'encontre de la Déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
la terre bien commun
mérite selon moi d'appartenir au plus
grand nombre
alors c'est des illusions loin de me
désemparer
ou ancré en moi l'idée
que je devais envisager l'agriculture
autrement
il est d'ailleurs temps que je vous
explique comment je me suis organisé
pour être un paysan heureux
en fait j'ai fait le choix de
l'autonomie sur la ferme
j'élève une trentaine de vaches 60
cochons de race local donc parfaitement
adapté au territoire les animaux vivent
en plein air
les vaches pâtures de l'herbe vous
mangent du foin pour faire du lait et
les cochons mangent un mélange de
céréales et les sous produits de la
transformation laitière c'est hyper
simple en clair j'ai rien inventé
sauf qu'avec notre système on produit
tout sur place ça nous rend indépendant
vis-à-vis des fluctuations de prix des
marchés internationaux et avec la crise
qu'on connaît actuellement sur les
matières premières agricoles notre
système a vraiment du sens
ensuite j'ai fait le choix de
l'interconnexion pour éviter l'isolement
et cloisonnement entre les mondes vous
savez l'entre-soi qu'on a tous tendance
à cultiver dans nos différents corps de
métiers
nous sur la ferme on est quatre paysans
associés ça permet de l'entraide des
échanges un partage des responsabilités
on partage le lieu avec deux artisans
qui eux travaillent dans le textile dans
le filage de la laine
moi j'adore les rencontres alors on
accueille régulièrement des stagiaires
des hoofers on organise des événements
culturels sur la ferme
on garde le contact avec les
consommateurs puisque nos productions de
Yahoo fromage ou charcuterie sont vendus
en circuit court à la ferme ou sur les
marchés
alors j'aurais pu en rester là
sauf que j'avais besoin de trouver un
statut juridique qui colle à mes envies
alors j'ai fait appel aux citoyens pour
constituer une SCI agricole et citoyenne
un statut juridique donc société civile
immobilière composée de 180 personnes de
tous âges sexe nationalité catégorie
sociale
ces personnes possèdent une ou plusieurs
parts dans la structure qui possède
aujourd'hui les terres et les bâtiments
de la ferme
en tant que locataire
occupant je paye un loyer un fermage
chaque année
pierre distribué aux différents porteurs
de part sous forme d'intérêt
ces personnes impliquées dans notre
ferme qui est également la leur me
soutiennent par leur engagement ils
viennent faire leurs courses
ils prennent de mes nouvelles
ou simplement viennent s'y promener en
famille entre amis pour découvrir notre
superbe territoire
on est très loin de la grille bashing
vous savez le prétendu conflit entre les
agriculteurs et les consommateurs
moi ma réalité est tout autre
je suis un paysan heureux
parce que je vis en accord avec mes
valeurs je considère que les terres
sont un bien commun
donc avec la propriété collective et
citoyenne on arrive à éviter que la
terre soit source de spéculation de
génération en génération
et soit la main de quelques-uns instance
privé comme public tout aussi obsolète
les unes que les autres
selon moi gardez le contact entre les
agriculteurs et les agrumes mangeurs
fait vraiment partie de la solution
alors je suis très impliqué dans le
projet de la ferme
et pour autant je me sens tout à fait
libre libre de faire évoluer la ferme si
mes envies changent libre car sans
contrainte vis-à-vis des financeurs ou
des fournisseurs
libre de changer de vie dans un an cinq
ans ou 10 ans
enfin je suis un paysan heureux parce
que je vis dans un cadre naturel qui
offre des conditions de vie incroyable à
ma famille à mes enfants
je vis à la fois dedans et dehors
j'ai 5 semaines de vacances je me
rémunère correctement
je mange des bons produits que je
fabrique
et j'ai la satisfaction de contribuer à
nourrir mes voisins en me levant tous
les matins
alors oui la situation de l'agriculture
est dramatique mais il n'y a pas de
fatalité il y a des solutions pratiques
à mettre en œuvre
notre planète a besoin de ces terres
agricoles notre pays a plus que jamais
besoin de nouvelles paysannes et de
nouveaux paysans nécessaires pour notre
alimentation à tous
alors si comme moi vous y êtes sensible
je vous invite à consommer bio et local
et à devenir copropriétaire d'une SCI
agricole et citoyenne près de chez vous
et vous verrez qu'en plus de faire usage
de votre pouvoir de responsabilité
alimentaire vous ferez des paysans
heureux
et croyez-moi ce bonheur c'est
contagieux
merci
[Applaudissements]